okay so recently had another question
from someone that wanted to know why
weren't they losing much weight after
doing keto for an entire month I think
they lost like five pounds okay and
their husband lost a lot more okay so
let's just kind of cover that because if
that comes up for you this may help you
the key or essence of how to get results
within a minute fasting and keto is to
decrease insulin that's the most
important thing you need to focus on and
that would be two things one is lower
your carbs number two decrease the
frequency of eating so if you're doing
three meals a day you gotta go to two
meals a day if you're doing two meals a
day and let's say you're 50 years old
and you're menopausal and your hormones
are slow you got to graduate to one meal
a day it might take some time but that's
what you're going to need simply because
there could be an underlying problem
with insulin that's so stubborn insulin
resistance that it's just not going to
happen unless you really cut down the
frequency of consuming food now the
other point I want to make is adjusting
your fats people have this idea that the
ketogenic diet is a high-fat diet and
you need to consume more fat like that's
gonna help you burn fat not necessarily
there's two types of fat you have your
your fat on your body that you want to
get rid of and then you got the dietary
fat the more you increase your dietary
fat well guess what the less that you're
probably going to burn on your own
body's reserve okay now fat is helpful
and necessary for a couple reasons
number one you need it for all the
cellular membranes for all the hormones
for your brain your nervous system so we
need that for structural purposes we
also need it
to help you be satisfied so you can go
long periods of time without eating
other than that you don't really need it
so in the beginning when you're doing in
a minute fasting it's very helpful but
as you adapt and you're not hungry
between meals and you're not craving the
need for dietary fat goes down why
because we want to force your body to
focus on burning off your reserve so I
wouldn't add any extra fat other than
the
that's already in the proteins that
you're consuming okay
and that's gonna help you so in other
words cut down the dietary fat that
you're doing if things if you want to
speed things up the other point I wanna
make is that how is your waist your
clothes okay are you losing inches if
you are then you know it's working vs.
the scale simply because a lot of people
start building a muscle mass and that
does have a heavier weight it has less
volume so you're going to shrink in size
but maybe not in weight because you're
building muscle at the same time as
you're losing and that's just a factor
you need to look at okay and now your
clothes feelin looser just realize
that's a really good indicator that is
working in your mind you may be thinking
that you need to be losing at least two
pounds a week to know that it's working
when in fact that's not true okay at all
if you're losing inches especially in
the beginning that means it is working
the last thing I want you to do is give
up when in fact it's working when you
think it's not working and stop the
progress okay so that's actually very
common by the way so you just have to
understand about the scale and that
scale is only one indicator that it's
working you have other indicators inches
lost energy level cravings going away
less hungry skin improved look at the
whole picture because it's about getting
healthy first the other thing you want
to do is focus on your sleep quantity
and quality there are things that you
can do with videos that you can watch
that I've done on increasing your sleep
quality and the amount of sleep that's
going to actually speed things up
tremendously also reducing your stress
because of the high cortisol if you're
worrying about losing weight 24/7
believe it or not that could have the
potential despite cortisol a little bit
more than it should and that can slow
you down so you almost want to do the
program not worry about it not think
about it now obsess about it and just
let the body do its thing but it does
take a little time that's why we call
you a patient and that's in fact well we
have a waiting room
you didn't know that yeah that's why all
right thanks for watching
so press the subscribe button and this
is misspelled
so I can't spell so I'm gonna have to
add that in here okay take two press the
subscribe button and up I can't even say
this press this it okay Jesus let me do
that over here press the subscribe
button press just press this button
right here subscribe okay that one right
there just do it right now what's the
next part what am I going to say take
five
do it and where am I going with this
press the subscribe button and I will
keep you updated on the future events